مشاهدينا مباشره الى جلسه الاستماع في
الكونغرس الامريكيه للرئيس التنفيذي لتيك
توك الى هناك
اذا مشاهدينا الان سنستمع الى هذه الجلسه
طبعا هذه الجلسه تاتي بعد ان اعلنت
الحكومه الصينيه نيتها معارضه خطط امريكيه
محتمله لاجراء لاجبار الشركه الصينيه
المالكه لتطبيق تيك توك على بيعه لشركات
اخرى بحسب ما تقول الولايات المتحده
لاسباب امنيه طبعا رئيسه الشركه تعرض الان
وجهه نظرها في اطار هذا الموضوع نستمع
وتشدد على الحاجه المستعجله للكونجرس
للتصرف فاننا نتحدث عن 150 مليون امريكيين
الذين يتواصلون مع معلومات حساسه ويتم
التحكم بها وهذا ما نراه هنا ونؤمن به لان
تيك توك كانت تقوم على الدوام بالكذب من
خلال
ما تقوم به الشركه الاصليه المؤسسه واليوم
يطلب من شركه مثل باي دانس ان تتوقف عن
اعمال التجسس اي بمعنى انه لابد لشركه
لشركات الصينيه ان تمنع عن قد عن التلاعب
الذي تقوم تقوم به والان
هناك نوع من التحقيقات بشان الانشطه
الرقميه والتحركات التي تقوم بها التيك
توك ونعلم ان عددا كبيرا من الموظفين
الذين يتبعون لبيجين التي تسعى من خلاله
لخلق باب خلفي للتصرف والتغلغل وبعض
الموظفين يقولون واقتلوا ان كل شيء يرونه
في الصين هذه ليست فقط الطريقه التي يمكن
من خلالها
من خلال هذه التصرفات التي تنموا على
التجسس ولا يمكن للعلم ان يتسامح مع هذا
الامر هناك بعض المراهقين الذين كانوا قد
شهدوا صورا لعمليات اباده جماعيه
لبعض الجاليات المسلمين لبعض الجاليات
المسلمه ومن خلال ما تقوم به
تيك توك فهذا لا بد من ان نشير من انها
تستهدف اطفالنا
وانها تلعب على
معنوياتي
الاطفال الابرياء وتتسبب بالاذن الشخصي
والنفسي للاطفال
فضلا عن التحديات التي تتركها من خلال
تعريضهم تعريض حياتهم للخطر
وهذا ما عاشته اسر كثيره من خلال
مشاهدتها لاطفالها
من خلال اللي تعملهم مع التيك توك هذا ما
تعملوا عليه الصين من خلال وصولها
بتطبيقاتها عبر الحدود وتسميم عقول
اطفالنا لا بد من
وقف في هذا المحتوى الذي يبعث على الياس
والانتحار والتحكم بالمحتوى الذي تقوم
نشره تيك توك هي لها تاثير كبير على حياه
الامريكيين وهذا يذكرنا بالحقبه السوفيتيه
التي كانت من خلاله انذاك
يتم بث افلام كرتونيه تحمل في طياتها
الكثير من المحتوى التجسسي تاكدوا تماما
ان هذه اللجنه تنظر في المستقبل ولا بد
للامريكيين ان يكونوا مستعدين لوقف
الادوات الرقميه التي تستخدمها الصين من
اجل العابها الخاصه لابد لنا من وقف اي
تطبيق لتيك توك يتم من خلاله تجسس على
الامريكيين وتقديم اكبر حمايه ممكنه
لاطفالنا ولهذا السبب فان هذه اللجنه تعمل
على ما وفقا لمعايير الخصوصيه
وتمنع من خلالها اعدائنا للتدخل في عقول
شبابنا وحياتنا وهذا سوف يجعل من تلك
المنصه
عرضه لمساله قانونيه للتحكم بمحتوى
بالمحتوى الذي يتم بثه
للشباب وشابات دون 17
واليوم العالم يراقب ما الذي يحدث
ما تقوم به باي دانس والحزب الشيوعي
الصيني يراقب لكن الاجابه التي يجب ان
تتوفر ان ان يتم توفيرها للشعب الامريكي
للشعب الامريكي الحر الذي يجب ان يتمتع
بحقوق
الحريه والسعاده ويستحق
ان يحصل على اجابه حقيقيه وصادقه امام هذه
اللجنه وهذا ياتي في سياق معرفتنا مما
تقوم به تيك توك في الفتره الحاليه
الان اعطي الكلمه
شكرا السيده الرئيسه دعيني اقول بانني
اتفق مع جل ما ذكرتيه واثمن هذا القدر من
الحماس الذي اشرت به في سياق حديثك عن
الاطفال
قامت بتحويل
المعلومات الى محتوى يتم من خلالها عمليه
مراقبه
ومن خلال جمع بيانات المستخدمين فان منصه
تيك توك يمكنها ان تقوم ببيع هذه
المعلومات من اجل درب المليارات من
الدولارات ولم يعد بمقدور الشعب الامريكي
ان يوقف عمليه
انتهاك الخصوصيه وهذا يتعارض مع التشريعات
الخصوصيه التي تجعل الناس قادره على
التحكم بمعلوماتها لابد من وجود حاله من
الشفافيه والمسائله
هذه اللجنه في الكونجرس كانت قد عملت مع
منصات اعلاميه اخرى حول المشاكل
والحوادث التي يتم من خلالها بوضع بيانات
وخصوصيه الاشخاص لابد من تيك توك ان تتحلى
بشفافيه التي تمتلكها
احدث شركات التابعه للحزب الشيوعي الصيني
في حين ان تقدم
حيزا مرحا
للمستخدمين لكنها في ذات الوقت تقوم
بانتهاك خصوصيه المواطنين الامريكيين ولا
اعلم اذا ما كان هناك فرصه ان يمكن من
خلالها وقف ذلك اكثر من 150 مليون مواطن
امريكيه يستخدمونه هذه المنصه التي تقوم
باختيار
وسرقه معلوماتهم الشخصيه من اجل خلق
لوغاريتمات تبعث على الادمان بحيث يمكن من
خلالها ان تستمر ببث محتوى تدفع المستخدم
لمجاهداتها مما ي غير من سلوكهم
ومعتقداتهم ان الحزب الشيوعي الصيني ومن
خلال
هذه المنصه وشعبيتها الواسعه
فهي تشكل خطرا على مواطنينا وعلى خصوصيتنا
هذه الشركه التي تتخذ من من بيجي المقر
انها تعمل لفرض
وجود اللهب في اماكن مختلفه من العالم
وحكومه الصين
الشيوعيه قد تقوم بتاثير على الاجهزه التي
يستخدمها المواطنين الامريكيين من خلال
نشر شيوعيه وتقويدي المصالح الامريكيه هذه
حمل الحمله حمله تشويه حمله تشويه
المعلومات من قبل تيك توك قد باتت واضحه
من خلال انشطتها غير القانونيه
واحاديث الكراهيه
واكثر من 80% من المعلومات التي ترد على
التيك توك تحتوي في
سياقها على
محتوى عن الكراهيه وكذلك تقوم بدرب
ملايين الدولارات للحكومه الصينيه لابد من
النظر في الحجم الاذى الذي تسبب به وخاصه
الاطفال الذين يعدون عرضه للمخاطر الذين
يستخدمون هذه الاجهزه وتسبب في مستوى كبير
من الكابه بين طلاب المدارس
التي تبعث عن هؤلاء المستخدمين لادمان تلك
المنصه ما يدفع البعض منهم الى الانتحار
والاذى شخصي وحاله من الغضب
ولابد من الكونجرس ان يقوم باتخاذ اجراءات
من اجل وقف هذا الذي يلحق بالمواطنين
الامريكيين لا يمكننا ان ننتظر الا ان
نعمل على تطبيق تشريعات حمايه الخصوصيه
التي نص عليها الكونجرس التي
هذا التشريع الذي يجب ان يضمن بان
المستهلك المستخدمين اينما كانوا في هذه
اينما كانوا في انحاء الولايات لهم قدره
التحكم ببياناتهم الشخصيه وبياناتهم وضمان
ان الشركه لا تقوم الا بمعالجه البيانات
التي يمكن خلالها تقديم الخدمات
وحمايه للاطفال والمراهقين لذا اعتقد انه
حان الوقت للدفع هذا التشريع ليكون قانونا
وانني سعيد
بالاصلاحات التي تمت على القسم اثنين
وثلاثه اثنين وثلاثين بحيث ان
هذه المنصه كانت على مر فتره طويله تقوم
بكل هذه الانتهاكات لذا الامل ان نصل
الاتفاق بين الحزبين حول هذا الموضوع بحيث
نستطيع ان نوقف هذا الضرر الذي تتعرض له
بلادنا والديمقراطيه اتطلع الى النقاشات
التي سوف نجريها اليوم في حين في مسار
الضغط
الوصول الى نوع من المسائله بشان وانا سوف
اركز كل انتباهي ليس فقط على تيك توك بل
على
المشاغل العامه التي تتعلق
بوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بصوره عامه شكرا
السيد الرئيس على عقد هذه الجلسه المهمه
شاهد لدينا السيد شكشو وهو
احد المدراء في تيك توك خمس دقائق
اعضاء اللجنه شكرا جزيلا انا
هذه هي البلاد التي
ترعرعرات فيها
وبعدها توجهت الى المملكه المتحده للدراسه
ومن ثم جئت الى هنا الولايات المتحده
وزوجتي من هنا وقد
ولدت وترعرعت في فرجينيا ومنذ بضع سنوات
اصبحت المدير التنفيذي للتيك توك واليوم
لدينا اكثر من
لدينا اكثر من مليار مستخدم اللي تيك توك
بما في ذلك 150 مليون مستخدم في الولايات
المتحده يمكن للناس ان يكونوا مبدعين
ولديهم حاله من الفضول بشان حاله الدكتور
هو كذلك الشركات الصغيره التي تعمل على
ايجاد مستخدمين مع
تنامي تيك توك قمنا
بالعمل على جذب اعداد كبيره من المستخدمين
وخاصه المراهقين في ان غالبيه المستخدمين
هم دون 18 فيتم اعاده النشر المحتوى الذي
يتم من خلاله دفع هؤلاء الاشخاص لمشاهدتها
مع ذلك تم وضع التدابير يتم من خلالها منع
ارسال اي رسائل نصيه بالنسبه للاشخاص
الذين هم دون 16 وهناك ادوات
لاولياء الامور التي يمكن من خلالها
الرقابه على الاطفال
ونود ان تكون تيك توك
منصه الاطفال ليتعلموا ولهذا يتم نشر بعض
الخصائص التعليميه التي
يتسنى للمستخدمين ان يتعلموا يتعلمون منه
وهناك اكثر من 150 مليون وجهه النظر
وتعزيز قدره الطلاب على تعلم الرياضيات
هناك بعض المخاوف
الامنيه القوميه التي ناخذها على محمل
الجد دعوني ابدا بالحديث عن بعض سوء
المفاهيم المتعلقه ببعد دانس التي نعد نحن
شركه فرعيه تابعه لها
ليست مملوكه برمتها من قبل الحكومه
الصينيه بل هي شركه خاصه 60% من الشركه
يمتلكها بمستثمرون عالميون
بالمئه من قبل الموظفين في انحاء العالم
واعضاء مجلس الاداارتها ثلاثه منهم منهم
امريكيون وتكتوك حد ذاتها
لديها مقرها الاساسي في لوس انجلوس
وسنغافوره لدينا سبعه الاف موظف في
الولايات المتحده اليوم
وكذلك لدينا مخاوف بشان احتماليه عدم
بشان احتماليه قدره وصول تيك توك الى
الولايات المتحده
وان مقاربتنا لم تقم بمعارضه اي مساله
تتعلق بالخصوصيه بل تطرقنا الى هذه
المسائل بالاجراءات المطلوبه
وهذا يعمل من خلال بناء
الجدران الحمايه لاي قدره وصول خارجيه
باختصار ان البيانات الامريكيه يتم
تخزينها من قبل لشركات امريكيه والاشراف
عليها من قبل موظفين امريكيين نطلق على
هذا المشروع
باسم الرقابه المطبقه في تيك توك في تكساس
واليوم
فقط الموظفين الذين
لهم صلاحيه يمكنهم الوصول الى البيانات
الشخصيه بالاضافه بالاضافه الى ذلك نقوم
بالابلاغ عن اي اي
موظفا ليمتلكه الامتيازات للوصول لهذه
المعلومات
ولدينا مقرات في سنغافوره انجلوس ونتوقع
ان يكتمل العمل في في هذين المقرين في
نهايه السنه وبعد ذلك سوف تكون كافه
البيانات تحت حمايه الولايات المتحده وتحت
رقابه
الوكالات الامنيه في الولايات المتحده
وعلى هذا الاساس فان بيانات خدمه
المستخدمين سوف تكون خاضعه للقانون
الامريكي وهذا الامر سوف ينطبق على
مبدا الشفافيه
الذي يخص تطبيق تيك توك
وحالها حال التطبيقات الاخرى مثل اوراكل
تستخدم اللوغاريتمات الذي يمكن من خلاله
ضمان نزاهه
الاستخدامات المتعلقه بهذا التطبيق ونمنحه
قدره وصول للباحثين من اجل الوصول الى
محتوى هذا التطبيق نعتقده باننا الشركه
الوحيده التي تقدم هذا المستوى من
الشفافيه
الثقه تتعلق بالاجراءات التي نتخذها ولابد
لنا ان نكسبها من خلال القرارات التي
نتبعها من خلال الخدمات والمنتجات ومساله
التلاعب بالمحتوى هي مساله غريبه لنا ولا
تخصنا ونعتقد بان ما نحتاجه هو وضع قواعد
شفافيه التي تنطبق على كافه الشركات
التكنولوجيا
والمسؤوليه تكون في في صميم ما نقوم به
ولا اختتم واقول باننا هناك اكثر من 150
مليون مواطن امريكي يستخدمون هذا التطبيق
ومسؤوليتنا هي حمايتهم ولهذا فانني اقدم
الالتزام التالي لكم ولكافه المستخدمين
اولا سوف نعمل
على الحفاظ على سلامه المراهقين في المقام
الاول ثانيا
سوف نقوم برفع البيانات
في امريكا ودون قدره وصول اي جهد خارجيه
ثالثا لن نقوم بالتلاعب بهذه البيانات ولن
نسمح لاي حكومه بان تقوم بذلك رابعا سوف
نكون سوف نتحلى بشفافيه وسوف نعطي قدره
للاطراف ثالثه خارجيا للرقابه انني ممتن
لاي تعليقات او اراء لكم بهذا الخصوص
كما تعلمون ان هذه الشهاده او هذه الافاده
التي تقدمونها هي خاضعه للقانون
هل من باب الدقه ان نقول ان
انكم بحكم منصبكم
كرئيس تنفيذي في سنغافوره هل تقدمون هذه
الافاده تحت
بحكم منصبكم كشركه فرعيه
في تيك توك
هل انتم على اتصال مع كيلي
رئيسه التحرير في بايدن لست على اتصال
مباشر معه وماذا بشانوه شوقين
الذي يعد عضوا في